I mean I'm part of a team that actually
gets things done rather than shouting
from the sidelines which is that all you
kids got to offer do they want a proper
local MP committee to them or do they
want a part-time I mean that's the
decision they've got to make here and in
me they've got a certain part of the
team that's delivered for not only South
Fanny but for the rest of the country
without manifesto launch today more good
news particularly for South Thanet in
terms of houses by taking people out of
tax I mean this is a stark choice this
is a suit we need to win if people want
a conservative majority government and
that's not like a song so off together
as a reality in just a few days time I
love it now that is one that would be
great it gets you
right
I need you man because I want to be one
of them because I'm going to be wrong I
think it's unusually more than many
others of the pieces to be honest with
you yeah we're one of those seats so we
are we have to hold to be able to form a
government and that's all we're seeing
down here are you expecting to get here
and expect to see to win this is a very
heavily you keep area we know why well
and I'm guessing is going to get it he
won't get I can tell you that because
the policies are going to its softening
all over the country
and I'm not from 20,000
I'm saying to them we now have a reality
check if you're concerned about the
european union who's going to give you
that referendum it's only us nobody else
Labour Party have ruled it out and you
keep them again and shout from the
sidelines but they won't actually be
able to deliver that so this is a
reality check a party that actually
delivers things with answers rather than
just spreading anger a referendum on the
EU we have today very clearly I'll be
voting out so not natural conservative
voters are thinking about us and we on
your average I'm not sure yet
definitely not you kidding right yep and
crappies you might have to think what is
the best way people of course of course
I'm quite happy but I'm very hopeful
actually that the the policy that we
have of making the benefit system in
Britain one of the toughest in the whole
of the EU for migrants will do
sufficiently exactly that the froth of
the numbers we're being very tough on
non EU immigration and I've got some
very hopeful that these numbers will
come down who could have expected just
five years ago would have had Iraq and
the Syria ratio creating so many asylum
seekers who could have even expected
with the eurozone going into crisis no
you'd have had Spaniards and and
Portuguese and Greeks looking for work
that was sort of awful not not expected
so we could doing something about that
in response to the new reality of Europe
but don't as long as I have you know
what a letter box is you know what it's
going to be like to open how difficult
and when there's a dog you have to just
put it in quick and run around here I
would say it's pension issues quite a
demographic and pensioners which we've
got triple our panel where they are we
hear about schools and we do have
grammar school system still in place in
Kent and very very famous grammar
suppose a grammar school boy not very
much favor of it I would like to mention
of the grammar schools yes no problem
that hassle I will say though an
immigration does come up from time to
time but it's coming up much much less
than it six months ago and I can give
people the answers I gave you earlier
and a quite satisfied that the central
part is a party of sensible government
that will respond to their concerns with
offices